NARRATOR: Rick and Charles,
along with Craig Tester
and Dave Blankenship, head
over to the Money Pit site,
where the team from
Choice Drilling
has already begun coring a
new borehole known as IJ 5.5,
an area chosen due to
its close proximity
to GAL-1, one of the team's
most promising shafts to date.
Hey, guys.
Hey.
RICK LAGINA: I am absolutely
interested in drilling
this position called
IJ 5.5 in search
of the long sought after
tunnel between shaft
6 and the Money Pit.
After that collapse in 1861,
the Money Pit location was lost.
And ever since then,
there's only been a guess,
an educated guess, mind you.
But if we can find that
tunnel, I think that's the way
to un-corkscrew the Money Pit.
So Brennan,
we're at 59, right?
That's correct, 59.
The reason why this
one is interesting--
when we drilled the GAL hole,
we found in the spoils--
they find a very old spike.
And we found a
gold-plated button.
That's our spot right there.
That's where GAL
is, GAL number one.
NARRATOR: Two years ago, in an
effort to locate the original
Money Pit, the Oak Island
team excavated a 40-inch-wide
exploratory shaft
which was named
in honor of Rick
and Marty's parents,
George and Ann Lagina--
GAL-1.
We've got coin!
Honest to God, a coin
out of this spoils?
NARRATOR: It was while searching
the spoils from this hole,
which was done to a
depth of 160 feet,
that the team made a number
of significant discoveries--
It says play,
and it's a button.
NARRATOR: --including a
gold plated 18th century
British military button,
a 300-year-old iron
rose head spike, and
a mysterious metal
hinge believed to have
come from some kind
of large box or vault.
Maybe that was part
of the debris field.
I'd never thought
twice about it.
Did you?
No, because we didn't
know where it came from.
Oh, OK.
Maybe today we'll
find the one thing.
Yeah.
That's the hope.
NARRATOR: If their
assumption is correct,
the team should be
able to locate not only
the original Money
Pit, but also what
they hope is a massive
underground debris field.
How are you doing?
How deep are we?
We're down about--
89 feet.
Close.
Well, here we go.
111 [inaudible].
111.
Yeah, it does.
Oh, that's interesting.
What do you got?
NARRATOR: While drilling
in borehole IJ 5.5,
Rick Lagina and members
of the Oak Island team
have just made a potentially
significant find.
Was that horizontal, Rick?
Yeah,
I think he hit the
tunnel from shaft 6.
NARRATOR: They have just
discovered evidence of what
appears to be a wooden beam
found at a depth of 111
feet, a depth which, according
to historical records,
matches that of shaft 6,
the 157-year-old searcher
tunnel that they
believe can lead
them directly to the original
Oak Island Money Pit.
RICK LAGINA: Today was a
good day on Oak Island,
in my opinion.
They do believe
we're in a tunnel.
And if we are, it's been
hard won, hard fought.
He's been looking for this
debris field since we started.
So it moves the
dial a little bit.
You find that tunnel,
you'll find the Money Pit.
I really believe this is
the tunnel from shaft 6.
Now, it's just finding
out did the treasure
chests shoot into this tunnel.
Yep.
There's something in 6.
- Let's find it.
- OK.
OK, gentlemen.
Thank you.